unterschiedlich sagt er unterstrich park
ist es im voraus schon abgestimmt wm
finale genommen wird also von den atari
mir ich jetzt gemacht habe
herzlich unter die leute und herz
willkommen zu einem neuen interview
leute ihr seht hier heute an meiner
seite meinen heutigen interviewpartner
psychose meiner interviewpartnerin leer
leer hat beim bachelor dieses jahr
mitgemacht bis 2020
[Gelächter]
irgendwie bin ich nicht angehört da
müssen wir schauen nicht auf mir jetzt
gerade vor dem hintergrund dass vor dem
motto willst aufnehmen der feuerwehr am
freitag den 6 vor zwei tagen ist das
bachelor finale angekommen könnte es
ganz interessant einmal ein blick hinter
die kulissen zu werfen deswegen vielen
dank dass du dir die zeit nimmst heute
und ich finds angefangen jetzt mal ein
paar ganz allgemein fragen 23 und was
machst du wenn du gerade nicht wenn
beispielsweise ein hier in hamburg und
arbeitet noch im fernstudium
ok dann würde ich sagen so weit zu den
allgemeinen fragen kommen jetzt so
anfangen wollte ihr habt mir auf
entzogen
es geht voran stellt übrigens lehrt
instagram lnk 140 sollen von dem neuen
text nicht gemacht hat eine empfehlung
von mir an der stelle
und jetzt geht's los zwei fragen 13
punkte unter schon gefragt wie kommt man
darauf damit zu machen also wie kam es
dazu und wie kamen die bekamen sowie die
motivation das zu machen
ja das war eine variation dass
verschiedene faktoren es ist einfach
selbst in der vergangenheit
das sind jetzt schon wieder getroffen
haben und am ende
ghosting da stand oder halt leer
ausgegangen sind oder was auch immer
unternehmens betraut war
oder wieso du soleil also ist eigentlich
immer sehr enttäuschend für mich die
letzten drei jahren in sachen männern
und dating los war und dann ganz wichtig
auch denke ich hätte lust ich kenne das
format hat schon länger in der
vergangenheit geguckt und ich wollte
halt auch mal müssen wir das jetzt
hinter den kulissen ist genauso wie ihr
euch das jetzt vielleicht einige fragen
gestellt die ich diese fragen auf und
dachte hey automatisch springen ins
kalte wasser und schaue was da wirklich
hinter den kulissen lux ist ja endlich
hat man natürlich auch lust drauf so ich
hätte lust mal das auszukurieren und
zwei hinzukommen oder gemacht
tatsächlich angenommen
ja ist ja auch was ich kann das
nachvollziehen man so einfach so wenn
man auf so was muss ja wenn man so ein
typ mensch ist ja auch irgendwie so
erlebnisse sucht ja es ist ja auch
lustig so jeweils wobei ihr wollt in
mexiko
seitdem nach mexiko geflogen habe dann
da gedreht das ja auch schon also auch
das können sie ist eine folge des
anderen
ich kann das format fraktionen deswegen
habe ich mich einfach dafür entschieden
zu bewerben und zu sagen weil es sowieso
mit mit freunden und sogar besser werden
oder weil das aber sowieso für dich
gemacht
tatsächlich entstand ist außerdem waren
sowohl ja es kann nicht sein dass jetzt
schon so lange single bis zum einmal
noch einmal nach dem wesentlich kurz-
oder keine ahnung habt ihr kopf zumeist
dann melde dich doch einfach mal im
bachelor vielleicht steht da der mann
weniger machen die anderen sagen ja
interessant das geht schon bisschen mehr
ins detail unterschiedlich sagt er
unterstrich falsch ist es im voraus
schon abgestimmt werden finale genommen
wird das ja nicht mit einer der
hauptfragen wahrscheinlich dieses die
leute stellen also sofern dieser frage
will ich jetzt gemacht habe da war das
nicht so dass da schon der bastian
stimmt zwar noch eine parallele für
aktuelle wetter ist auch an sebastian
und blond für mich kann das schon so
weit auf eher da quasi die entscheidung
getroffen hat dass ich das auch offen
gehalten hat also zu keinem zeitpunkt
kann ich das gefühl dass sie in den
schatten
interessant sind auch einige orte lassen
ich denke dass das alles vor profis
rüttelt das ne das ist alles vor nicht
dass nur fahrrad aber ich kann mir auch
tatsächlich gut vorstellen dass ich da
auch so dass er mehrere eigendynamik
drin ist was man von außen sind
wir haben nie irgendwelche texte
vorgekommen wir haben noch nie die
chance stelle zweimal zu trinken auch zu
den themen und aus dem auto aussteigt
und erstmal hinfliegt ich nochmal die
chance ins auge gehen und dann noch mal
elegant auszusteigen
also das war alles wirklich realisiert
wir haben auch gerade eben leute sagen
da ich schon ein bisschen gesprochen und
sind auch auf einen punkt gekommen ist
können wir ihn an der stelle gerade
einfügen du meintest nämlich dass
tatsächlich die gespräch auch groß
größten kamera stattfinden müssen
ja also das ist halt so in der mädels
villa haben wir unten diesen
wohnzimmer bereich die küche esszimmer
und dann hat noch den außenbereich und
das liegt halt überall da sind überall
kameras installiert und dementsprechend
wirst du halt gefilmt wenn runden dich
aufhält und es wird schon sehr darauf
geachtet dass das geschehen dann am tag
wirklich dort in der villa und nicht
irgendwo anders im haus hof vielleicht
keine kameras installiert sind was
natürlich einfach dazu dies ist
verständlich ist für den zuschauer also
nach möglichkeit halten sich dann alle
in diesem kameraüberwachten oder mit der
kamera gefilmt bereich auch und dann
soll je nach geschlecht und je nach
material sind also ich glaube wenn ich
jetzt den besser produzieren will ich
auch sagen dann material trend sichtbar
zu machen schloss natürlich welche deals
groß ist hat so vorstellen wenn man alle
zusammen vielleicht im badezimmer ist
und so das war's denn die und damen
gehen weiter zusammen runter und
unterhalten sich weiter
der anschluss durch das finde ich
richtig froh dass ich so schlecht
verkaufen dürfen die kandidaten ihr
handy behalten dürfen also nicht nur
handy ist alle elektronischen geräte
quasi das gut mache
ausgenommen werden nein also wir dürfen
unseren es tatsächlich nicht behalten
wir hatten auch vor ort keinen fernseher
werden keine bücher gesellschaftsspiele
oder sonst was wir mussten uns da mit
uns selbst und den mädels beschäftigen
und sind auch auf ganz kreative ideen
teilweise dann kommt herzlich und
irgendwie wie lange war das ganze zeit
in der behalten oder ja genau also also
wie lange du kannst du sagen wie lange
kann man sich kann man sich vorstellt
wird wird so was ungefähr so einige
wochen ein türke und was ist mit der
zeit dann schon
geht es geht an die substanz muss auch
immer diese entscheidung vielleicht
selbst auch betroffen dürfte hingehen
möchte aber wenn du wirklich den ganzen
tag immer gefilmt wird vor ort ist
bekommst du nur raus wenn du kein geld
hast also lust bastian sein wirst du du
du das hört sich jetzt hier sind wir
ganz und gar keine ablenkung hast ich
bin halt ein mensch ich stehe mal so ein
bisschen unter feuer ich musste mir was
machen aber da ich habe den ganzen tag
geschlafen und hab die ganzen tag
gegessen und vielleicht eine stunde
sport gemacht mit den geräten die uns
zur verfügung gestellten aus soja
darüber aber nicht nur in das sollte
sport machen und dann ja dann also
bestimmen ist nicht nicht gleichwertig
und finde studium ja aber da habe ich
gedacht ich hätte einfach die 200 kilo
banken gab es doch einfach durch
minister punkt heling wie hat die
teilhaber beim bachelor dein privatleben
beeinflusst wenn mein privatleben dann
sehe ich jetzt mal was freunde und
familien gibt gar nicht genauso
vorher wird diese menschen einen meiner
engsten und natürlich kommen halt leute
auf dich zu vernehmen und vielleicht
lange nichts mehr gehört hast oder du
wirst auch das vielleicht leute und dem
gefühl was zu tun hat dass hinter den
welche das nun negativ darauf reagieren
vor allem in dem moment als es dann halt
gepostet habe dass ich dabei bin und das
wird ihr dann auch zugetragen was ich
super super schade fanden teilweise ja
es hat vielleicht ein bisschen was
beeinflusst
darum gehen problem für mich halt jetzt
nicht so viel mit meinem thema
tierrechte aber also private auch
schlichen sich also mit sicherheit geben
sie nach außen als man das als auch da
sich die familie gegen einwände nicht
sagte aber ich glaub ich nicht so
gemeint dass du in deinem privat in
anderen bereichen für erlebtes also zum
beispiel dass du auf die straße geht
angesprochen wird ist oder so was ja das
ist schon passiert und das ist total
surreal für mich wenn ich das jetzt ein
gebot
ich war vielleicht eben jetzt ich glaube
dass folge sieben dabei war jetzt sieben
mal im fernsehen zu sehen und sprechen
wirklich leute an
obwohl auch schon auf ein foto mit ihm
machen kann natürlich weniger gespielt
aber fühle mich jetzt nicht weiter nach
personen werde mit der andere leute
einfach foto machen kann ich also ein
stück heute hab ich ja als manchmal euro
durch youtube auch mal so erfahrung
gemacht dass man also so viel kann man
sich nicht wirklich
man kann es nicht so eilig zu er ist
jetzt fix unterstrich da wieder 19 gibt
es oft zickenkrieg unter den mädels also
ich bin halt jemand der sich auf sowas
nicht einsetzen also ich glaube es ist
sehr sehr schwer sich mit mir zu
bestreiten oder gar nicht anzeigen
ich versuche viel mehr zu vermitteln
ihnen irgendwo streit ist in meinem
umfeld und vor ort natürlich dies ein
paar aufregende situation so du bist
einfach den ersten tag in dieser villa
eingesperrt mit menschen die du nicht
wirklich gut kann ist dann natürlich
auch noch frauen ist vielleicht auch das
ein bisschen exklusiver ist ja es kam zu
so ein paar zickereien waren für mich
aber banalitäten sind und ja hat sich
dennoch relativ schnell erledigt und ich
war eigentlich nie immer wir ja das hat
also ich glaube das ganze set up ist
schon darauf aus oder es birgt schon ein
bisschen sprengstoff sohn übertragen
sind also dass keine handys als
ablenkung keine elektronischen geräte
kaum andere aktivitäten also dann sitzen
alle im haus auseinander und
konkurrieren noch um dieselbe person um
einen mann den viele einfach gut finden
das kann nur eine lernen vielleicht dazu
meine frage von mir als du dich dafür
beworben aus als erwartet wurde
hattest du da schon quasi so ein bild
von diesem bachelor aushängen und da
wurde gesagt okay das ist quasi unser
wetter 2020 hast du lust mit dem diner
du weißt ist eigentlich nicht meine
steht bei mir war das so einen tag bevor
ich losgefahren bin damals stand zur
debatte das erstmalig bei einem
flatterband ich war natürlich voll
aufdreht und habe mein handy gekauft und
werde google gibt es eine vermutung
schon weil es gibt ja immer im vorfeld
ein paar vermutungen wer sein könnte
erst recht dann also da gab es irgendwie
artikel über ihn und ich glaube ich habe
mir auch also die überschrift durchlesen
ich wissen geschieht aber insgesamt kann
man machen wenn er das denn
und dann ist es auch geworden ja also
ich gab ihr 60
okay das war dann in der ersten mal bin
ich aus dem auto ausgestiegen und ich
wahrlich sicherheitsverwahrung an sieben
gesetzt da unwetter uns die ganzen leute
mussten da die hand um räumen das ganze
zimmer abbauen aufbauen und ungarn
aber ja deswegen war es nicht so
klassisch bei uns in die ganze staffeln
davor und ich bin ausgestiegen und dann
stand ein großer gut aussehender mann
und mir wurde aber gesagt wer abgeholt
also es kommt jemand der guten schlaf
und dann verstehen und sie ist etwa
erste abdullah
[Gelächter]
also wenn das letzte jahr kein zufall
war
elisa 6.7 warst du gar nicht
eifersüchtig auf die anderen ist ein
versuch zum thema gewesen
also ich würde sagen ich bin generell
eher so eine person die ihren versucht
unter kontrolle hat ich glaube immer
wenn ich manchmal hat man immer so ein
bisschen sorgen und so eine leichte
später immer mit rein aber so in
sehr sehr gesunden maße bei mehr und
klar in der situation weiß einfach für
welches format du dich beworben hast du
weißt dass du einfach noch andere frauen
sind die um diesen mann kontrollieren
dementsprechend sicherlich falsch damit
sagen dass er sehr gut besucht einfach
rein zu gehen
zum echten leben ist gut finden in
meinem freund oder partner den stellte
noch zwei drei andere nehmen
das würde gar nicht geht absolutes novum
12 aber wenn du nicht ein bachelor
selbst kann sich ausgehen dass die
einzige bis die da auf der jetzt
eingeladen wird und einzige wissen die
da geküsst wird und hatte seinen folge
statt alles vorbei weil es kaum platz
gefunden hat so funktioniert dass da
einfach nicht und dementsprechend würde
ich sagen ich bin auch mit ein bisschen
anderen einstellung als im normalen
leben ins trockene also ein bisschen
relaxter und somit habe man muss ja auch
darin den raum bringen
wie war es denn in dem moment wo du
erfahren hast das für dich jetzt da der
der ausstieg aus der villa wo vorstellt
also ich habe es ja nicht gerade
ok ich muss elf lange nicht hatte nächte
da wurden und bei denen ich eigentlich
ein schlechtes gefühl hat einfach weil
ich ihn zu dem zeitpunkt schon gerne
mochte muss ich sagen und deshalb
gewünscht hat immer weiter zu kommen
aber weil der nacht der hosen habe ich
mich tatsächlich relativ sicher gefühlt
also ich habe nicht damit gerechnet an
dem abend rauszufliegen
[Musik]
und danach war so ein bisschen perplex
ich war auch traurig ich musste das erst
mal fünf begreifen
du musst jetzt auch vorstellung waren an
einem flughafen essen
mega cool ist in so ein helikopter steht
der endung rum
kameras sind auch die drauf und dann auf
einmal links sowie jetzt kommt
vielleicht mal name ja eigentlich auch
nicht gerechnet
ich finde es auch immer wenn ich noch
mal drüber nachdenke
das sind ja letzten endes wirklich sehr
sehr sehr intime geschehnisse aus deinem
leben wo einfach permanente kamera drauf
ist nimmst du das in dem moment war
nimmst du das in dem moment war wenn
jetzt irgendwie sich ostsee an wartet
allerdings also manchmal ich werde auch
gefilmt sie ist die kameras da und aber
so wie wir es dass dieses element ich
werde gefallen sind
also ich weiß natürlich nicht wie das
bei den anderen mädels waren hier muss
ich sagen ich hab die kameras die auf
senden klicken zeit geführt und auch als
erste christen feiern ist auch sehr
schön war
ich konnte mich nicht wirklich viel dass
wir jetzt mit normalen leben verdanken
dass du mein vater meine mutter auch
also es ist ja nur ein kurs das ist
nichts schlimmes ganz im gegenteil aber
trotzdem ist im moment so vor als
deutschland guckt aber zu glauben man
kann die gedanken sind einfach da in dem
moment ich bin sowieso jemand der
eigentlich relativ viel nachdenke und
dem was auch ein bisschen schwert mit
manchmal den kopf abzuschalten und
gerade noch so viele kameras auf die
drauf sind so dass sogar nicht kennst
auf seiner vergangenheit ja schon schwer
glaube ich hast du dir sieht man die
auch tatsächlich das ist nicht so blöd
kann man das schon denn vor allem auf
donnerstag vorstellen du liegst ja
einfach und doch nicht du bist halt zu
zweiten versuch
du bist nicht zu zweit und du hast
vielleicht auch einfach themen diese
abfrage im laufe eines kennenlernen
super richtig sehen
überhaupt sind die wirklich unbedingt
die aber sehr sehr privat sind und die
also ich hatte ein
diese an sich ja das ganze hat auch
schon ein gewisses maß an absurdität
also sehr interessante situation es ist
gute frage von x11 sich da wieder 19
werde die rosen aufbewahrt also dürfte
die behalten oder werden die
weggeschmissen
wir haben quasi was vorteile
ich denke die leute mich gehört aber
hinter mit dass das sind die originale
rosen von sebastian
jetzt hat sie einander so was temporär
natürlich nicht mit aber das sind die
die die original rosenfeld staaten ging
also fünf stück so etwas jetzt zwei
hatte ich dann glaube ich nicht mehr
dabei aber ja das sind die leute die
rosen sind verwelkt dramatische musik
bitte und filter oder space sie rosen
sind für weltweit ist okay leute damit
eine teil eines interviews teil 2 und 3
werden den nächsten tagen kommen lehrer
ist wieder völlig irre meinte
vorstellungsvideo erproben könnte man
kann ein bisschen raus bist und was dann